welcome to this new video by simply
learn in the Symphony of personal and
professional growth upskilling is the
melody that harmonizes ambition with
achievements stepping into 2024 getting
upskill and make a move with the
technological Trends can be a right
choice to get a career growth today here
in this video we are going to share top
10 SE tools for 2024 by upscaling with
these tools you can see the real impact
on your skills and career however if you
are the one who is looking to get
certified in 2024 then you are at the
right place introducing per your
postgraduate program in digital
marketing which will be your all over
companion with this program you will not
only ace in content writing but also
keyword research search engine
optimization behavioral marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and much more with these
technical expertise you will also gain
complete Hands-On learning with the
tools like Google Keyword planner chat
GPT Google ads Google analytics and
there are more than 30 tools in the list
reserve your seats first enroll now from
the link in the description box and pin
command before we begin with top SEO
tools for 2024 consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us let's
begin with the number one tool in the
list which is sem Rush sem Rush provides
the best digital marketing Services if
you are looking for SEO content
marketing competitive research PPC and
social media marketing all in one place
then semrush can be the right choice for
you semrush provides a few are listed
below keyword research onpage SEO
competitor analysis content marketing
local SEO rank tracking social media
management link building competitor SEO
analysis market analysis SEO
optimization and much more semrush is
available in free and paid plans one can
access very few features using the free
account however the paid plan starts
from $1 1229 per month the next tool in
the list is ahrs ahrs launched in 2011
is a prominent SEO tool widely used for
website optimization its key features
include site Explorer for backlink and
traffic analysis keyword Explorer for
Effective keyword research content
Explorer for discovering popular topics
rank tracker for monitoring keyword
rankings site audit for identifying
technical SEO issues and compet data
analysis for strategic insights ahref
also offers link building tools aiding
users in finding and acquiring high
quality back links coming to the pricing
of the tool ehf provides a lot of free
SEO tools however to make most of the
features mentioned above pricing starts
a $1.99 per month moving to the next
tool which is Google search console
Google search console formerly known as
Google web master tool is a vital free
service for the web Masters and SEO
professionals it offers key features
like performance data for search
insights index coverage to address
indexing issues URL inspection tool for
detailed URL views site maps for
Effective crawling mobile usability for
mobile friendly checks security issues
alerts core web vital insights for page
experience and links and manual actions
monitoring regular use helps in
optimizing sites fix issues and enhance
online visibility making it an
indispensable tool for SEO speaking
about pricing Google search console is
free of charge next we have is Mose Mose
has several digital marketing tools
either free or paid some key features of
most includes keyword research
competitive research rank tracking link
research domain overview site crawl and
much more when it comes to local SEO and
web visibilities products from MOS
provide 30 days free trial of the tools
and the paid version starts at at $1.79
per month moving ahead to the next tool
which is SE ranking SE ranking tools are
vital for digital marketing and SEO
offering insights into the website
performance search engine visibility and
SEO Effectiveness the key features
includes keyword tracking for monitoring
rankings competitor analysis for
understanding rival strategies site
audits for comprehensive Improvement
suggestions backlink analysis for
assessing link profiles and Reporting
and analytics for tracking SEO impact
local SEO features cater to businesses
targeting local audiences while social
media integration provides a holistic
online presence view these tools come
with userfriendly interfaces for easy
navigation by both beginners and
experienced SEO professionals speaking
about the pricing SE ranking has free
trial and paid plans starts at $144 per
month next we have is Google Keyword
Planner Google Keyword Planner a part of
Google ads platform is a crucial tool
for refining the advertising strategies
it helps users to discover new keywords
estimate search volumes assess
competition and plan advertising budgets
by inputting relevant terms or a URL
user can uncover valuable keywords and
understand their potential reach the
tool also provides insights into a level
of competition and assist in the
Strategic budget Planning by offering
bid and daily budget estimates note that
the features May undergo updates so
users are encouraged to refer to the
latest Google ads documentation for the
most accurate information utilizing
Google Keyword Planner empowers
advertisers to enhance campaign
Effectiveness through careful keyword
selection and strategic budget
allocation talking about the pricing
then Google Keyword Planner is free tool
to discover keywords as per your
business requirements next we have is
Google analytics Google Analytics a
powerful service by Google enables
website owners to track and analyze
traffics and user Behavior the key
features includes monitoring website
details analyzing user Behavior
identifying the traffic sources tracking
conversations and e-commerce data
creating custom reports and dashboards
assessing realtime analytics audience
segmentation and seamless integration
with Google products it aids businesses
in making data driven decisions
optimizing user experience and
maximizing online impact the platform
also offers features for data privacy
compliance such as gdpr now talking
about the pricing Google analytics
provide the tools that are free of cost
which helps in understanding the user
journey and Roi in marketing moving to
the next tool which is answer the public
answer the public is a powerful and
insightful tool that serves as digital
Oracle in the world of content Creation
with the ability to transform user
queries into a visual landscape of data
it empowers creators to unearth the most
pressing questions and concerns of Their
audience by delivering into the
collective curiosity of the online
community answer the public not only
provides the answers but also
illuminates the pathways to meaningful
and engaging content it stands as a
beacon of content strategies guiding
them through the vast sea of information
to craft content that resonates with the
heartbeats of Their audience in the
Journey of content creation answer the
public is the trusted companion that
turns inquiries into Inspirations and
helps Creator to navigate the ever
evolving landscape of audience interest
answer the public tool comes with a free
trial and a paid subscription starts at
just do5 per month next we have is US
SEO us SEO is a powerful WordPress
plugin that simplifies onpage SEO it
offers userfriendly content analysis
customizable page titles and and meta
descriptions XML site Maps social media
integration readability checks Focus
keyword optimization a redirect manager
and breadcrumb navigation regular
updates ensure the alignment with the
latest SEO practices making it an
essential tool for enhancing website
visibility and Performance used Su is
available in free and premium versions
where premium version starts at $1.99
per year moving to the last one on the
list which is screen screaming frog
screaming frog SEO spider is a powerful
website crawling tool for SEO analysis
it conducts in-depth site audits
analyzes URL structures Access Link
profiles renders page for Su insights
generates XML s maps integrates with
Google analytics and allow custom data
extraction with regular updates it's a
valuable resource for quickly
identifying and addressing various SEO
issues to enhance website visibility and
performance screaming frog has both free
and paid versions paid versions starts
at $12.59 per year so here we wrap up
top SEO tools for 2024 if you like this
video hit the like button share the
video with your friends and consider
subscribing to Simply learn to stay
updated with the latest Technologies
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success
click the link in the description to
know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn n it up and get certified
click
here